I want to start by saying congrats on
this movie you guys did such a great job
and it's a worthy sequel to t2 so I just
have to start with that
my first question of course is going to
go to you with Tim Miller helming
Deadpool and helming this who wins in
the fight between the t800 and Deadpool
well the Terminator always win did no
chance for Deadpool he's a lightweight
sorry Tim I understand um one of the
things about this film though is t2 is
beloved it's one of my all-time favorite
films people absolutely revere it how
nervous were you nervous at all about
doing like a real follow-up to t2 did
that ever because it's so revered I was
extremely worried about doing a
follow-up but it wasn't for the fans it
was for I just didn't wanna let Sarah
Connor down so I don't work for I mean I
appreciate fans and love that we have a
fan base please don't let me sound
ungrateful
it's simply I can only work to please
the director or please the character you
know barely even myself it's just I want
to make the director happy and I want to
bring Sarah Connor to life and I just
wasn't sure that I was up to the task
nor do we really know who Sarah Connor
is I mean the her situation has changed
and it was a script that was very in
very rough form and we all had many
dialogues about where is she you know
where has she been but ultimately you
know you the the thing that terrifies
you is where you should go in my world
so I decided to jump on board were you
ever nervous I don't think this is my
style you know it's like you you fall in
love with a story and I liked the story
I liked the idea of bringing Linda back
and to have Jim be part of it and be the
creator of it so I felt like we went
good hands with Tim Miller directing it
and with the cast that they have cast it
was fantastic
so it's it's in a movies is about story
and it's about cast and so I thought
that
we have a good start there because we
have a great story in the great cast so
I was never really worried when I
committed that oh my god can I live up
to the success of the first one or the
second one any of those kind of things I
mean imagine that every Olympic athlete
that goes into the Olympics worries
about can you tap the record' or can you
be better than the last guy there's not
the way you compete you just go in there
and say I'm the greatest now I'm going
to compete now end of story
one of the things I really thought was
fantastic in this is the action
set-pieces
Tim did a great job at making it so you
could follow along easily could you sort
of talk about crafting the action with
Tim and what impressed you about the
collaboration mmm I'm glad that he makes
it so that you can follow it I know he's
got a really great sense of action and
you know visual effects
I however couldn't follow this action
worth crap even in reading the script I
was like but what what I mean because
there's so many of us off doing our own
little things and we're weightless and
you know we're in the air and we're in
the water and we're on land that last
sequence was just almost too much for me
to comprehend but Tim had prepared
previz so that's pre-visualization
scenes animated for us to be able to
drop into our characters mentally and
understand what's going on around us and
I had to rely on it a lot things have
changed a lot in my day since my day and
it was just great to have those visual
cues to really keep up with Tim but he
he's on his best game he's just a
fantastic visionary and I love him to
death want to work with him again